- So I just have to ask
'cause everybody's a
huge fan of "Star Wars".
Do you have any kind of tease?
I know you can't, like, say too much, but.
- It is happening.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering)
- Solid news.
- Yeah.
I know the general story-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which is very cool.
- [Kelly] It's been a minute though
since you've done something.
Like, it's been, like,
how long since the last?
- Well, what's crazy is time passing.
It was like 11 years ago when I got cast.
- [Kelly] That's, right?
- Yeah, I was a baby.
- You're still a baby, says your skin.
You're welcome. From genetics, yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah, so it's been, and then it's been,
yeah, quite a few years-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Since I've been part of that world.
- Kind of cool to jump back in the role,
like, that many years later, right?
- Yeah, and also strange
'cause I was the baby
and now I'm like, oh, I'm
gonna go in as, like, you know,
I, like, got married and done other stuff.
And, like, I feel more
like a grown up now.
- Yeah.
- So I'm looking
forward to it.
- A real woman.
Yeah, I like it.
I'm excited.
You have so many projects and you said,
the one I wanna mention real quick,
you said, is it "Magpie"-
- "Magpie", yes.
- [Kelly] That you're working on?
And that's the one you
did with your husband?
- Yes. That is premiering at
South by Southwest in March.
- Oh, awesome.
- Yeah.
- Very cool.
- [Daisy] Yeah.
- All the things in the air,
you're floating all the things.
Let's take another break, everybody.
Daisy's movie "Sometimes
I Think About Dying".
It's just a fun title to
say. It's in theaters now.
Be sure to check it out.